investigators here in New York are
trying to determine why a required
self-closing safety door did not close
leading to 12 deaths in the deadliest
apartment fire in the city since 1995
children were among the dead four others
were critically injured the fire started
three days after Christmas on one of the
coldest nights of the year it took first
responders only three minutes to arrive
but not in time to prevent a tragedy
caused by a three year old toddler
playing with the stove
FDNY Commissioner Daniel Nigro the
mother was not aware of it was alerted
by the young man screaming she exited
her apartment with these two-year-old
and three-year-old and left the door
open that was a fateful mistake
according to the commissioner like smoke
up a chimney the fire was sucked into
hallways the entire five storey building
was engulfed within minutes
ten-year-old Chris Belle Martinez
escaped with her brother the victims
range in age from 1 to 63 among the dead
a mother her two daughters and niece a
family member didn't want to go on
camera but the heartbreak was obvious
so they're beautiful in another
apartment a woman and infant were found
huddled in a bathtub four people are
still in the hospital fighting for their
lives in all a hundred and seventy
firefighters were called in to fight the
blaze the cold weather made things worse
crews battled the flames with freezing
hoses according to city records the 100
year old building has a number of open
safety violations including a defective
smoke detector on the floor where the
fire began the Fire Department is
investigating whether that played any
role in this tragedy